Доброго дня Вітаю вас Слава Україні
Отже Кабмін вирішив
перекласти про які саме категорії
йдеться чому ухвалили таке рішення
Я дуже дякую котрий раз що ви цікавитесь
проблемами освіти адже це про майбутнє
по-перше це було доручення президента
при зустрічі його з студентами і ми
чітко розуміємо що російська агресія
спричинила
певні проблеми в родинах родинах в тому
числі студентів там де ми сьогодні перш
за все В умовах воєнного стану маємо
вжити всіх заходів для підтримати
найбільш вразливі категорії осіб саме до
цієї категорії ми відносимо студентів
фінансово спроможність яких не дозволяє
сплачувати за навчання через вплив
російською агресії по уборкування і які
мають отримати державну підтримку
продовжити замісувати освіту саме
головне мета була президента уряду і
Міністерства освіти в тому щоб ці діти
не Поїхали за кордон та виконання
завдання президента Володимир
Зеленського уряд затверджували рішення
про переведення на навчання за коштів
державного бюджету окремих ка можливість
здобувачів коледжів Паркове переміщення
освіти і закладів вищої освіти які були
зараховані на навчання до 21-го року
учня тобто другий третій четвертий і
другий курс магістратури
досі категорії ми можемо віднести діти
загиблих захисників України та учасники
бойових дій та особи з інвалідністю
внаслідок війни діти учасників бойових
дій і жителі особливо небезпечних
територій
саме важлива категорія яка така не
досить зрозуміла на сьогодні але яка
прописана в постанові це мешканці
особливо небезпечних територій Це
території об'єднаних територіальних
громад що розташовані в зоні проведення
воєнних або бойових дій які перебувають
тимчасових окупації оточені блокування і
які визначені наказом не їм реабілітації
від 25 квітня 202 року номер 75 станом
на 15 жовтня 22
це підтвердження статусу здобувача
освіти який має подати для підтвердження
статусу здобувач освіти має подати витяг
з реєстру територіальної громади які
підтверджує відомості про місце
проживання або перебування особи станом
на 24 лютого 22-го року або документ про
освіту який здобутий до 24 лютого 22-го
року в закладі освіти розташовано на
території цих територіальних громад пане
Сергію Скажіть будь ласка а є якісь
склад є якісь конкретні терміни для
подачі оцих витягів з реєстру я чому
питаю тому що Ну от на частині
Херсонської області там взагалі немає
інтернету
на сьогодні немає ніяких термінів ми
працюємо з кожним
подавачем заяви індивідуально здобувач
подає заяву і ми опрацьовуємо її в
повному обсязі Ми ні в якому разі не
обмежуємо здобувачів освіти щодо подачі
цих
А скільки таке рішення коштуватиме
бюджету і звідки братимуть гроші на
нього
Звісно це дуже дороге для бюджету
рішення але немає нічого дорогощого ніж
наші громадяни України нічого вирощує
адже наші громадяни України і ті
громадяни які будуть відновлювати нашу
державу на сьогодні
принаймні
велика оцінка яка стосується саме цього
рішення це від 7 до 9 мільярдів гривень
до 2025 року включно і державне
замовлення фінансується за рахунок
загального фонду державного бюджету ви
розуміємо що фінансуючі ці витрати за
рахунок податкових
надходжень під час війни неможливо
в 22-му році це сума становить понад 300
приблизно 370 мільйонів гривень 23-й рік
3,9 млрд 24-й рік понад 3,3 млрд пана
Сергій У нас зараз така непроста
ситуація
Ну я маю на увазі масовані повітряні
атаки російської армії на цивільну
інфраструктуру в зв’язку з цим Як ви
будете міняти
освітній процес і чи багато регіонів
вирішать відмовитися від очного навчання
Або можливо когось із дітей ви
відправити на канікули в зв'язку з цим в
тому числі раніше
знаєте Дуже гарне запитання адже на
сьогодні в Верховному контакті з
департаментами освітньої науки з
засновниками закладів освіти
незважаючи на спроби рашистів у складах
і життя українців і зокрема забезпечити
нормальну освітній процес поки що Ми
визначаємо позитивну динаміку і
позитивну тенденцію повернення учнів до
ученого або змішаного навчання станом на
сьогодні 24 жовтня 2022 року в нас
освітній процес відбувається в 12 тисяч
школах причому 383 це традиційна форма
повна форматне навчання
6340 - це онлайн режим і 353 це змішане
навчання для того щоб процес освітніх
дистанційному форматі був максимально
доступним ми завдяки нашим партнерам
щоденно зміцнюємо матеріально-технічну
базу формуємо
уроків доповнюємо їх додатковими
матеріалами і Хоббіт нас багато в чому
навчив і війна ще більше навчила наша
діти не мають бути відлучені
ми не зупиняємось на досягнутому і
тільки від початку
війни ми вже домоглися про значну
допомогу від наших донорів щодо онлайн
навчання від наших партнерів несуттєво
наповнюємо онлайн контент і суттєво
використовуємо в тому числі і світові
інформаційні ресурси дуже дякую.
канікули Вибачте На Саме основне
відповідно до закону України про охорону
загальну середню освіту в графі канікул
графік освітнього процесу визначають
засновники і педагогічна рада директорів
шкіл в цьому контексті ми ми на сьогодні
об'єктивно формуємо
рекомендаційні листи враховуючи і стану
опалення станом енергетичною безпеки
стан взагалі засвоєння матеріалу не
можна сказати що цей процес формування
канікул є об'єктивним і стаціонарним для
всієї країни кожен з засновників
визначає свій графік освітній процесу
але при цьому я хочу зазначити освітяни
свідомі і в тому форматі в якому ми
сьогодні
формуємо освітній процес загальний
процес формування канікул розпочнуться з
29 жовтня у більшості
загальноосвітніх закладів України а і
також є певна певний період циплята
листу
дякуємо вам за роз'яснення Сергія шкала
міністр освіти та науки України